gunfire in downtown Conakry frightened
residents have locked himself indoors
taking cover from ginny's paramilitary
forces who are shooting live rounds in
the streets but we're supposed to be a
nationwide protest against president
alpha Conda has turned into street
battles between security forces and
demonstrators armed with sticks and
knives they say they are here to defend
their democracy we tell Cooper
enough of course we are spared but we've
managed to paralyze the city and turn it
into a ghost town to show our
frustration with our leadership the 81
year old president wants a referendum to
change the constitution so that he can
run a third term in office but his
political opponents are against a
referendum they don't trust the
president to organize an impartial vote
like in a versus Guineans need an honest
leader one that treats all of it citizen
fairly equally irrespective of the
ethnic origin fairness ethnic the ethnic
Fulani make up the majority in Guinea
and yet never has a Fulani been in power
many of them are out protesting accusing
the government of arresting them in
discriminating against them this is one
protester that has just been arrested
and this is what's happening throughout
the capital in the country paramilitary
police deployed to try to arrest and
stop any form of violence security
forces shot dead several protesters and
scores are injured
Human Rights Watch accused the
government of banning street protests
for over a year now and cracking down on
dissent presidential elections are a
full year away but the political
deadlock has already set in there is a
sense of fear an apprehension of what is
to come
Nicholas Hawk al-jazeera conakry